what do you need to know before you jump
into the mi B's next chapter I will
Chris Hemsworth and Tessa Thompson take
to the black suits will we get to see
Will Smith and Tommy Lee Jones rock the
ray-bans in this one we've got a primer
to get you ready for men in black
international based on what we can
gather from the trailers
it appears that Tessa Thompson's
character is Agent M a new recruit
center partner alongside Chris Hemsworth
agent age to crack a murder mystery and
prevent a new alien threat Thompson's
character seems to get us start with the
men in black by discovering their New
York City headquarters before being
dispatched to the organization's London
outpost
although the film is international it's
important that the movie begins in my
say after all the city was essentially a
main character in the original film
barry sonnenfeld director of men in
black made sure that the movie was set
in the Big Apple as part of a joke that
New Yorkers would barely notice alien
life living among them in the first
movie 18k tells agent Jay that the MIB
in New York was created right before
alien visitors arrived on our planet
just outside New York in the 60s aliens
you made contact March 2 1961 outside
New York
however the upcoming movie takes place
all over the world with a production
shooting in England Morocco and Italy
these are countries that are obviously
far older than the United States and may
reveal a deeper history of aliens on
planet Earth than the earlier movies let
on when word got out men in black
International was on the way the big
question on everyone's mind was whether
we would see Will Smith and Tommy Lee
Jones back in the saddle in the film's
trailer fans are treated to a J&K Easter
Egg a painting on the wall depicts
Smith's agent Jay and Jones's agent Kay
fighting the insectoid alien from the
first movie of all the characters
themselves make a cameo in the new film
the initial word was that Smith and
Jones would not participate since then
however some comments from director F
gary Gray have led to speculation that
we could see a cameo from the original
duo or we can do is hope gray is
directing international from a
screenplay by Matt Holloway and art
Markham the duo who wrote
2008 Siam man Steven Spielberg is back
as executive producer the role he served
on the original trilogy besides
Hemsworth and Thompson Liam Neeson will
play the head of MIB London there was
unclear how much screen time the
character will get a spin-off has a
strong supporting cast as well Emma
Thompson will reprise her role from men
in black 3 as agent o he may
and eonni is playing a comedic alien
sidekick and Rebecca Ferguson has signed
on as a lead likely as a villain
battling Hemsworth and Thompson the
original films were beloved not just for
being fantastic adventures with
out-of-this-world aliens on technology
but also for that humor first I was
gonna pop this guy hanging from the
streetlight and then I realized you know
he's just working out and how would I
feel somebody come running in a gym bust
me - while I'm on a treadmill in
addition to Will Smith's gift for
physical comedy and Tommy Lee Jones is
patented deadpan the films also succeed
as satire
making keen insights about race and
immigration after all the first movie is
about alien visitation by intergalactic
refugees seeking asylum given today's
political climates you can look back a
man in black as a progressive parable
about taking a compassionate approach
the immigration policies Tessa Thompson
certainly does telling E W I mean the
start of the first move he talks about
immigration and Will Smith as he's
really searing jokes about race I think
you do have the chance inside of all of
this escapism to say something
men in black international further
solidifies the franchise as comedy chops
of director F gary Gray who directed the
comedy classic Friday on the acting side
of things humor on Jionni known for the
big sick and Silicon Valley is sure to
bring laughs still we can't forget Chris
Hemsworth it's easy to only imagine
Hemsworth as a god of thunder but with
brilliant turns in Ghostbusters vacation
and SNL Hemsworth is building quite the
comedic resume Tessa Thompson is no
slouch in the comedy department either
considering the hilarious moments she
shared with Hemsworth in Thor Ragnarok
it's no surprise that fans are excited
to see the pair reteamed have done the
black suits the international trailer
hints at more of the cool weapons and
technology that become a hallmark of the
Men in Black Series in one clip fans are
treated to an array of secret weapons
revealing themselves from within a sleek
black car in addition to the futuristic
laser guns the trailer also provides a
decidedly light-hearted low-tech moments
in which agent H throws a hammer as an
alien adversary looks like a tales of
turn
how incredible catch it's certainly not
the first time one of Hemsworth's hammer
tosses didn't go according to plan
I didn't think sure
[Music]
the trailer also features the most
iconic it might be gadget to fall the
neuralyzer ironically one of the most
memorable aspects of the original menon
plaque was this memory erasing device
used to make witnesses forget everything
about agents and alien life-forms the
inclusion of the neuralyzer in the
trailer is a nice nostalgic touch and
the basically a necessity for any MIB
sequel and then there's a franchise's
signature look you know differences
between you and me
I make this look good that's iconic seen
to find a big aspect of the series
appeal the style if the trailers are
anything to go by the names might have
changed but the effortlessly cool of
minimalist look hasn't gone anywhere
the sleek cars are also a crucial part
of the MIB series and it looks like
Internacional won't disappoint on that
end in London we see the aforementioned
spy car with secret weapon racks a 1970s
Jaguar XJ later in the trailer we also
see Hemsworth in Thompson riding in a
Lexus RCF sports car in a nod to the
1980s Ford LTD Crown Victoria in the
first movie the RC F can also fly at the
press of a big red button check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]